this week on Brian Ross investigators
Reefer Madness the old scares about
marijuana are giving way to legalization
across the country now some states even
offer advice on how and where to light
up a joint if you choose to smoke
cannabis do it away from other people
well-known figures including former
Republican house leader John Boehner are
going into the marijuana business even
as the federal government continues to
see it as a dangerous business currently
the federal law on marijuana is the same
as it's been since basically 1970 and
that says marijuana is a schedule one
substance which equates it on the same
level as heroin plus Russia's secret
Killers it's called the Wagner group
brutal mercenaries with a track record
of murder and war crimes now dispatched
to Ukraine it is I think a statement of
Mr Putin's desire to bolster his
Manpower in response to the depletion of
that Manpower over the last six weeks
we'll get the latest from a top expert
and this week's winners and losers in
the media see if you agree with the
editors of mediaite I've got no
connection we're sitting in the entrance
she says and they're shelling the shit
out of us from the studios of the long
crime trial Network in New York City's
Herald Square this is Brian Ross
investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us I'm Brian Ross joined as always by my
colleague Rhonda Schwartz and Rhonda we
begin with the growing movement to
legalize marijuana in this country
Reefer Madness no more has more than a
dozen states have passed laws to
legalize pot and business seems to be
booming even as Congress continues to
resist changing the federal laws on
marijuana Rhonda that's right Brian and
every year thousands of people are still
being arrested for possession of
marijuana while prominent officials
including house former house leader John
Boehner are in the marijuana business
and now more states are poised to join
the reform movement
a new state law takes effect in Colorado
today making it the first state to let
anyone over 21 walk into a shopping
legally buy recreational marijuana at
the stroke of midnight on New Year's
California will become the eighth state
to legalize recreational marijuana
marijuana Madness the first day of legal
pot sales in Illinois draws a lot of
customers from Wisconsin breaking news
recreational marijuana is now legal in
New York it's a historic day for New
Jersey you can now legally purchase
recreational marijuana if you're 21 or
older we're joined Now by Eric Altieri
who's the executive director of normal
the National Organization for the reform
of marijuana laws and Eric thank you so
much for being here there's such a
patchwork quilt of state laws around the
country how does anybody know what's
legal what isn't legal
sure um well it does make it a bit
tricky um given that depending on where
you are in this country
um having a couple joints in your pocket
can go from being perfectly legal as if
you had you know a six pack of beer at
your house two being a felony or very
serious criminal charge so it's
understandable that individuals might be
confused going state to state well this
change is taking place state by state
what is the federal law on marijuana
well currently the federal law on
marijuana is the same as it's been since
basically 1970 and that says marijuana
is a schedule one substance which
equates it on the same level as heroin
which says it has a high potential for
abuse and health problems and has zero
recognized medical value which is
something that clearly the dozens of
states with medical programs and the
countless studies that have shown its
efficacy would disagree with and is
completely in conflict with the 18
states plus Washington DC instead of
fully legalized marijuana for adults
from the point of view of the federal
government still refer Madness
and the ultimate end of the marijuana
addict
hopeless Insanity
still Reefer Madness still just say no
um if Nancy Reagan were around she would
recognize federal marijuana law because
it's just the same now as it was then
unfortunately I mean that's where we
really run into challenges the federal
government needs to get its head out of
the sand I'm going to address this
tension between state and federal law
and go towards ending marijuana
prohibition which something the
overwhelming majority of Americans want
and what's the impact for this Gap the
lack of a federal law
that trickles down in a lot of ways um
one there's still thousands of people
that are arrested under federal law for
marijuana every year um and deal with
that federally even though most
marijuana arrests are at the state level
about 98
um it also creates issues and states
that have moved to legalize where since
a schedule One Federal substance these
businesses that are spring up across the
country are unable to use Financial
Services like Banks and credit card
processors that any other business would
do requiring them to be cash only
businesses which makes them targets
personally and their customers targets
for potential crime and violence from
unsavory elements and it continues to be
an issue in terms of how that Innovative
hacks individuals with criminal records
for just marijuana possession even at
the state level you can lose your
financial aid for college you can be
thrown out of your public housing you
can have your children taken away simply
for having a marijuana charge on your
record even if it's just possession for
as little as a joint
Eric are people still being arrested for
possession of marijuana even just a
joint as you say
yes um that's the sad truth of it um
largely for years and years
um you despite all this progress you see
at the state level about half a million
Americans have been consistently
arrested every single year for marijuana
possession over the past decade we've
seen that start to come down a little
with States legalizing and obviously
kovid had an impact but as of last data
that we have from the government across
this country about 350 000 Americans
were arrested for marijuana possession
last year and that's something that I
think most people don't recognize that's
about one arrest every minute or so and
how many people would you estimate are
behind bars having been convicted of
possession of marijuana not selling it
but possession
sure that's a much harder number to
really get a hold of simply because
Prison populations are very transitory
and the government doesn't put out a lot
of data but there are certainly
thousands that are in prison but it's
really also not just the issue of
getting arrested and put in jail it's
those ancillary costs for the rest of
your life those opportunity costs you're
gonna have to check a box on your job
applications with this charge in many
states so you won't be able to get
employment so you can lose your housing
you can lose your children so getting
arrested even if it's a one two day
experience of being thrown in the local
jail you're still going to have to deal
with those problems for decades to come
and see your future really diminished in
a lot of ways that I don't think almost
anyone in this country believes it
should be as you know for years critics
have said that marijuana is sort of the
gateway drug it opens the door to others
becoming more involved with cocaine and
heroin given the legalization now across
the country what evidence is there that
that was in fact true or false
there's zero evidence that that is true
um the Gateway theory is a theory
um I'll use air quotes on it that has
been around for decades and been
debunked time and time again the fact is
that well over 50 percent of all
Americans have consumed marijuana at
some point in their lives and we've not
seen that transition into high levels of
hard substances in any way with a causal
relationship when you take marijuana out
of those back rooms and back alleys and
you put it behind the counters of
licensed businesses you don't have that
connection or you and you don't see that
any real transition of individuals from
marijuana consumption to harder drugs
and if anything we've seen it's what we
call really an exit drug there's been a
huge body of research in the past decade
that shows that marijuana has
successfully helped individuals with
heroin and opioid addiction wean
themselves off of that by taking a less
harmful substance like marijuana to
substitute it and then ultimately get
off the substances all together
and finally have you seen evidence
anywhere at all of health risks and
Hazards because of the use of marijuana
are people using it more and are they
exposing themselves to some kind of
health risks
well thankfully all the scary
apocalyptic Visions uh prohibitionists
claim would happen with legalization
never came to light if anything we've
seen some positives around that we've
seen decreases in opioid use in states
that have had medical or legalized laws
and things of that sort but you know
that's not to say marijuana has zero
risks involved it's not right for some
people it maybe it doesn't agree with
them or based on their own medical
history but things like that you can
really address only through a regulated
market through public education
campaigns New York state has legalized
cannabis and to help understand what
that means we are starting the Cannabis
conversation who can use where to use
and how to safely use by telling people
the truth and giving them the actual
data they need to make smart decisions
about their bodies their lives and what
they consume all right Eric alturi the
executive director of normal thank you
so much for being with us here tonight
coming up next Vladimir Putin's secret
army a band of mercenaries now
dispatched to Ukraine said to be even
worse if that's possible than the
Russian army you're watching Brian Ross
investigates on the law and crime trial
Network